[Music]
breaking news this Tuesday night
missiles strike Poland what we know
about the deadly hit and whether Russia
is responsible we will get to the bottom
of what has happened the danger it could
trigger a wider War
the hot commodity of children's cold
medicines accusations of price gouging
and amplifying calls for Mass mandates
no answers and no action assessing the
federal government's promise to tackle
homelessness
plus they call him the boss I followed
his Trail up close and personal with
banff's biggest and baddest grizzly
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us we begin with
a potential escalation of Russia's war
in Ukraine Poland's foreign Ministry
says a russian-made missile landed in
its territory and killed two people it
says they don't know who fired it and
there is no independent verification the
missiles are Russian Poland is a NATO
member though and any deliberate attack
on it could trigger a wider conflict
this video circulating on social media
shows a crater and an overturned trailer
it is said to be near Poland's border
with Ukraine not far from leviv Russia
denies it fired any missiles into Poland
though it did launch a fierce
bombardment of missiles across Ukraine
today Poland's prime minister
immediately called an emergency meeting
of the country's National Security
committee and increased the Readiness of
its military Poland's president urged
calm tonight and has spoken to the
American President Joe Biden offered
America's full support into the
investigation NATO allies including
Canada are monitoring all this extremely
closely so is our Europe bureau chief
Crystal gemancing Crystal what did the
Polish government say tonight Donna
polish officials have confirmed that two
of its citizens were in fact killed in
Poland in the village of peshevaduf
that's about 10 kilometers from the
Ukrainian border and tonight officials
are on that site trying to confirm if
the explosion and the fatalities were
the result of a Russian missile strike
but polish officials are not waiting for
that confirmation they have already
increased the Readiness of the military
from the very beginning of Russia's full
invasion of Ukraine there were concerns
about the fighting in Ukraine spilling
over into Poland and that's why early on
we saw NATO bolster Defense Forces along
the Eastern flank right across Eastern
Europe there is Swift reaction coming in
from officials in Latvia Lithuania
Estonia as well as the president of the
European commission Ursula vonterline
tweeting out that she is alarmed by the
reports coming out of Poland Russia's
defense Ministry by the way put out a
statement they are denying that a
Russian missile was the result of this
strike in Poland calling media reports a
deliberate provocation and attempt at
escalating things of course as you
mentioned Donna we saw a fierce increase
of strikes by missiles across Ukraine
today Ukrainian officials reporting
about 100 missiles being targeted at the
country all right crystal damansing in
London tonight thanks Ukraine is not a
NATO member and though the West is
supporting Ukrainian forces we're not
engaged in direct combat with Russia if
there has been a deliberate attack on
NATO soil though that could change and
Canada a NATO member would be part of it
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is with me Mercedes it is a
tense time what are the next steps in
terms of NATO's response
it is Donna and what's expected next
from all the sources I've spoken to is
that there may be Article 4 invoked
that's basically a meeting and it's a
meeting that happens whenever member
states feel that their territorial
Integrity or security might be
threatened it's very different than
article 5. Article 5 is an attack on one
is an attack on all and that's only been
invoked once in NATO history and that
was by the United States after 9 11. but
even Article 5 is not an automatic Call
to Arms for those who are feeling
anxious about what's happening tonight
there's a lot of discussion that would
have to happen and a lot of belief that
this would have to have been deliberate
and worth a military response before
that would happen one of the senior
folks in the military who I was spoken
speaking to earlier tonight said to me
look if we put this into Russia's hands
and allow them to decide what the
trigger was was something as simple as a
single strike we would be out of control
the reality is at the end of the day
this will largely be decided by the
United States of America and of course
it will depend on whether or not this
was a deliberate or an accidental strike
and that's something that really is
still being determined at this point so
likely at this point Donna that it would
be article four not Article 5 which is
basically a meeting that's been invoked
seven times before in fact it was also
invoked when Russia initially invaded
Ukraine by seven NATO members who were
concerned about their territorial
Integrity including Poland this would
not be the first time that Russia has
potentially accidentally struck a
country that is not Ukraine they hit
Moldova back in October but there was
less discussion on that because Moldova
is not a NATO country the military
sources I spoke to also told me the
Russians have largely run out of
precision Munitions they are using
dumber and dumber bombs and they don't
have great discipline or leadership
which could account for a strike so of
course we're waiting to find out what
happened but all those things come into
consideration what is Canada's response
at this stage
well Donna at this point it's pretty
muted we heard from Melanie Jolie who is
the Minister of Foreign Affairs she's at
the G20 uh very recently take a listen
to what she had to say
so obviously we're following up this
situation very closely uh we're in
contact with Poland as well as with our
partners
um my heart is with the family and loved
ones of the victims and also with the
people of Poland just kind of believe
this triggers article 5.
we're following up this situation very
closely and of course we'll be having
important meetings today with allies
so as you can see there Donna very very
careful there's a lot of phone calls I'm
told by senior officials going on behind
the scenes to the United States Poland
NATO and even they're trying to find out
from Russia what may have happened here
but right now everyone is being very
careful with their words a reminder
there are 40 Canadian combat engineers
currently in Poland but there's of
course no suggestion that they were
involved anywhere near the strike but
for those wondering about Canadian
Forces there that's who's in the region
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thanks
Russia's war in Ukraine dominated the
G20 Summit in Indonesia today the
Russian President Vladimir Putin is not
there he sent his foreign minister
instead Canada is among those pushing
for G20 leaders to call out Russia's
aggression at these meetings as
Mackenzie gray reports Russia's invasion
of Ukraine was brought up during a brief
informal chat between prime minister
Justin Trudeau and the Chinese president
Xi Jinping on the sidelines of the G20
he's the elephant in the room Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavrov arriving
at the G20 in Bali
welcome by the Indonesian president who
has the unenviable task of trying to
bring together a group of countries that
have almost nothing in common in the war
does not end
it will be difficult for the world to
move forward one of those countries that
could help stop the war China whose
leader had a quick conversation with
Justin Trudeau on the sidelines of the
G20 it's not the full bilateral sit down
that the U.S South Korea and Australia
had but it was an opportunity for the
prime minister to raise key Canadian
concerns a senior government Source says
Trudeau brought up Chinese interference
in Canadian elections with President Xi
Jinping Global News was the first to
report that China allegedly interfered
in the 2019 federal election by
funneling nearly a quarter million
dollars to 11 different candidates it
was a good conversation and it is
important to indeed keep channels open
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
also met with her Chinese counterpart
but wouldn't say what their reaction was
to the alleged interference we won't
tolerate any form of foreign
interference at large in Canada period
so it's not a discussion it's
intolerable so that's our position
Canada also made its position clear on
Russia behind closed doors a senior
government official says that lavrov
repeated conspiracy theories to world
leaders claiming the U.S were operating
bio labs in Ukraine and that the who
blocked a Russian vaccine the next
speaker Justin Trudeau who told lavrov
his claims were a quote absolute garbage
after the meeting lavrov got the final
word saying countries like Canada were
the ones that provoked Russia into
attacking Ukraine
lavrov left the summit late Monday night
but not before having to listen to a
20-minute speech from Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski who
addressed the G20
I'm convinced now is the time when the
Russian destructive war must and can be
stopped zielinski said with lavrov's
departure from Bali it opens up the
potential that the remaining countries
could be able to find a consensus
tomorrow on a final communique that
might be tougher on Russia Donna all
right Mackenzie gray in Bali Indonesia
thank you prime minister Trudeau has
pledged 750 million dollars to further
Canada's indo-pacific strategy it's the
largest chunk of money put towards the
plan so far you're marked to finance
infrastructure projects in Asia over
three years
now to news in this country Canada's
public health agency confirms what
parents and hospitals are already seeing
a flu epidemic is underway its weekly
flu watch report shows Canada's
positivity rate was nearly 12 percent in
the week ending November 5th that is
nearly double the number of cases
reported the week before this flu season
is surging faster and earlier than past
years and we have already crossed the
five percent epidemic threshold
hospitalizations are on the rise
especially children and compounding the
problem is a shortage of pain and fever
medication nitu garcha reports there's
been more of this and less of this and
while the federal government has assured
one shipment of children's pain
medication from the U.S has arrived in
Canada it won't say how much qualities
have been established but because of
confidential business information I'm
not able to share them it's confidential
how many doses Canadians can expect to
receive of a medicine for their children
that there's a shortage of it's the
information of those companies that are
importing Federal officials say more
details about its newly secured sources
of cold and flu remedies from abroad
will be made public soon and another
shipment of product from Australia is
expected later this month Health Canada
confirms it's aware of price gouging of
products like children's Advil and
Tylenol listed for nearly 300 on Amazon
and has raised the issue with the
retailer the product listings now seem
to have been removed
another worry for parents and overrun
Health Care system is leaving Long waits
for sick children requiring hospital
visits across the country
in BC this retired ER physician is with
a group calling for an immediate
Universal mask mandate to not act is
basically facing the system to be
overwhelmed and so that when you or your
loved one need health care there's going
to be nobody in the emergency department
to see you in a timely fashion but BC's
Health Minister says the message hasn't
changed masks continue to be recommended
indoors but don't expect a mandate this
is a big country we're seeing a lot
higher respiratory illness amongst
children right now in Ontario than we're
seeing British Columbia in Alberta the
message isn't quite as clear the premier
there refusing to answer whether she'd
recommend the use of masks look I've
said that anybody who wants to wear a
mask can feel comfortable wearing a mask
I'm not going to be mandating them
meanwhile one of Alberta's biggest
school districts in Edmonton is asking
the province for Clarity on what it
would take to issue a mask mandate amid
a wave of viral illnesses that send
sending thousands of six students home
to their parents who are often unable to
provide them any medication nitugarsha
Global News New Westminster BC
prime minister Trudeau's National
Security adviser believed last February
so-called Freedom Convoy protests posed
a serious threat that assessment came in
an email tabled as evidence at the
inquiry into whether the use of the
emergencies act to end those protests
was warranted our chief political
correspondent David Aiken was watching
the proceedings David this advisor is a
senior bureaucrat in Canada's defense
and security establishment
well that's right Donna her name is Jody
Thomas and she became the prime
minister's National Security and
intelligence advisor in mid-January two
weeks before the Convoy rolled into
Canada's capital
and after the Convoy had been in Ottawa
for two weeks on the eve of the federal
emergencies act being invoked Thomas
described her view of the protests in an
email read into evidence at the
commission on Tuesday this is about a
national threat to National interest and
institutions She Wrote by people who do
not care about or understand democracy
who are preparing to be violent who are
motivated by anti-government sentiment
that email was sent within minutes of
another message Thomas sent to a senior
RCMP intelligence officer asking for an
assessment about the threat of these
blockades the characters involved the
weapons the motivation clearly this
isn't just covid and is a threat to
democracy and rule of law now Thomas
herself will not testify until later
this week and she almost certainly will
be asked how she came to hold these
views that the Convoy represented a
threat to democracy what was the
evidence to support these conclusions
but as the prime minister's National
Security adviser Jody Thomas's
assessment of the blockade almost
certainly would have been one of the
most influential heard by the Prime
Minister and his cabinet as they decided
to invoke the emergencies act last
February Donna David Aiken thanks
remorse and regrets coming up what
Hockey Canada's former CEO had to say
about the organization's so-called slush
fund
[Music]
Hockey Canada has spent more than one
and a half million dollars on crisis
management since its handling of alleged
sexual assault cases was exposed and it
was hit by bad press and lost
sponsorships the revelations came to
light during the organization's fourth
appearance in front of a special
parliamentary committee today Hockey
Canada's former Chief Executive said he
regretted not doing enough to tackle the
conduct of athletes outside the rink
I wish I could go back I wish I could
have put more policies in my job as CEO
was to really run the operations
policies came from the board and I'm not
deflecting that back to the board I was
the CEO and I should have been
encouraging more policies
Bob Nicholson was CEO for more than 15
years he says he oversaw the formation
and a maintenance of so-called slush
funds used to pay out alleged sexual
assault cases however Nicholson stressed
he was not involved in the day-to-day
operation of those funds
Girl Guides of Canada says brownies its
Organization for seven and
eight-year-old girls will get a new name
we've heard from these catalysts youth
racialized folks current and former Girl
Guide members who've told us that the
name brownies causes harm
we are sorry
Girl Guides say the change is designed
to remove one of the barriers that may
keep some girls or their families from
wanting to join the new name will be
announced in January
trouble tracking promises ahead the
report criticizing Federal efforts to
cut homelessness
[Music]
Canada's record on reducing homelessness
is in the spotlight tonight the auditor
general says the federal government
doesn't actually know whether its
efforts are curbing the crisis despite
the Liberals spending nearly 6 billion
dollars since 2018 the government can
say whether homelessness has increased
or decreased it's one of four government
performance reports released today and
there's a Common Thread Federal
organizations are often slow to use the
means at their disposal to make a
difference Eric Sorensen reports
every year in this country close to a
quarter of a million people experience
homelessness five years ago the liberal
government laid out an ambitious goal to
cut chronic homelessness in half by
2028. how's it going nobody knows says
the auditor general there isn't
sufficient data to measure outcomes you
need the information to be able to
measure where homelessness is when you
start and then whether or not you're
actually making making a difference
infrastructure Canada and Canada
mortgage and housing Corporation really
have a big data Gap we do have some data
the federal housing Minister cited tens
of thousands of people who have escaped
homelessness the last three years but he
says Community groups didn't collect as
much data as hoped because they were
coping with just getting through the
pandemic we need to do better in terms
of the collection and the analysis yes
and that part of the part of that
depends on the community entities and
they were facing the challenges of cobit
and we understand in a separate report
the auditor general says indigenous
Services Canada has not done enough to
support First Nations preparedness for
emergencies like floods this past spring
Manitoba's peguis first nation was
inundated twice for years the community
has called for preventive infrastructure
to divert flood waters that have
destroyed homes multiple times the AGS
report says in emergencies across the
country three and a half times more
money has been spent on response and
recovery than on measures to prevent and
prepare for emergencies in the first
place the minister says all levels of
government will have to step up this
really is going to be an all hands on
deck sort of shift from reaction only in
rare circumstances to the prevention and
adaptation that's going to be required
as we see increasing events like this
every single year so why aren't they
taking the actions needed the
frustration says Karen Hogan is that
many reports of the auditor general
follow previous ones that governments
simply have not acted upon Eric Sorensen
Global News Ottawa
boss of the Bears next how a
photographer stumbled upon one of
Alberta's most infamous Grizzlies
if you are hiking in the Rockies or
anywhere really it is wise to avoid
Bears or at least warn them you're in
their territory and then there's the
bear known as the boss he's a huge
Grizzly with a reputation and an ability
to survive where others have not and so
when a photographer in Alberta had a
chance to encounter with the boss twice
in one day he knew it was something
special Heather York's West has the
story
in and around Banff National Park his
exploits are legendary the boss a
Grizzly as big as they come he's also
really good at occupying habitats around
people without coming into conflict with
people and so that kind of just creates
this scenario where he is well loved
over the years the boss has made plenty
of headlines there was the time he was
spotted eating a black bear or when he
survived being hit by a train he's also
believed to have fathered more than 70
percent of the area's Cubs
but while hearing about his Legend is
easy in these parts seeing the bear up
close in person is another story
so when award-winning nature
photographer Jason Leo bantle spotted a
set of fresh Grizzly tracks in the snow
he went to investigate at this time of
year you don't want to go follow a
grizzly bear so I actually followed the
grizzly bear backwards I followed his
Trail backwards I just had curiosity I
did a masters in biology and I love to
know about animals after finding the
Bear's Den bantle returned to his
vehicle and I couldn't believe it about
a half a kilometer down there was yeah
the back of a bear with snow on it it
was glistening in the sunlight from the
safety of his car battle was able to
capture these rare and up close images
of the boss and that evening in the
evening light as the sunset he came
through the meadow and just this
beautiful lumbering bear and his element
the encounters made all the more
meaningful because of the animal's age
the boss is believed to be over 20 years
old and Grizzlies typically live 20 to
25. it's why battle doesn't take these
stunning images for granted or the time
he got to spend and in the presence of a
local Legend he's the boss there's no
question about it
Heather urich's West Global News
wow look at that face that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is the
city of Cold Lake Alberta living up to
its name we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
[Music]